deux millions de doses le kazakhstan
démarre ce mardi la production du
spoutnik v le vaccin russe contre le coc
vie 19 objectif une vaccination massive
prévue avant la fin de l'hiver
la vaccination de masse avec le spoutnik
vfabric et au kazakhstan débutera en
février 2021
la vaccination bénévoles concernera au
premier chef les soignants les
enseignants les étudiants les forces de
l'ordre ainsi que le personnel des
établissements médicaux et sociaux et
les représentants des groupes à risque
souffrant de maladies chroniques
au total ce sont plus de 50 pays qui ont
demandé à la russie de leur fournir les
doses de ce vaccin made in moscou la
palestine par exemple en recevra quatre
millions en janvier
elle est l'un des nombreux pays a
préféré le vaccin russe et ce pour une
raison bien précise
la possibilité de conserver de stocker
les doses de vaccins entre + 2 et + 8
degrés celsius au lieu des - 70 de ses
concurrents européens et américains
autre avantage la dose de spoutnik v est
moins cher et pourrait être disponible
en plus grande quantité que celle de ses
concurrents après les commandes du
royaume uni des états unis ou des pays
de l'union européenne le fonds russe
d'investissements directs chargé de sa
commercialisation a également annoncé
une possible combinaison avec le vaccin
britannique astrazeneca numéro 1 des
commandes pour une plus grande
efficacité
cette collaboration entre deux
producteurs de vaccins est unique et
j'espère qu'elle nous permettra de mieux
nous protéger
je pense également que cela va stimuler
la coopération partout dans le monde et
que les gens prendront cette relation en
exemple le spoutnik v serait également
efficace face aux nouvelles souches du
virus
découverte en europe ces derniers jours
a déclaré vladimir poutine ce lundi
les premières livraisons devraient se
faire à partir de janvier 2021 vers
l'inde le brésil la corée du sud et la
chine